[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
linking the two of these folks together
is still going to provide a modicum of
prejudice
a major decision in the cases against
chad dabel and lori valo
in the deaths of her children briana
taylor's mother
calls kentucky's attorney general a liar
after he failed to indict
most of the officers who pulled the
trigger and killed her daughter
plus a convicted chicago cop killer
learns his fate
and a former professional baseball
player on trial for triple murder
police say he fled the crime scene and
then attacked a k-9
it's almost like an old wrestling move
where the dog kind of was picked up
and then dropped on his top of his head
long crime daily covers court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to law and crime
daily i'm erin keller along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin we begin in
idaho where a so-called doomsday cult
couple is accused in the deaths of two
children
prosecutors want chad dade bell and his
wife lori vallo tried together
the pair is charged with conspiring to
alter conceal or destroy evidence after
the bodies of valo's two children
were discovered buried in daebel's yard
they're not charged with murder
lorie valo's attorney is not objecting
to having the trials at the same time
but chad dabel's attorney is the state
says the evidence and the witnesses
against the couple
are the same both of the deceased
children were found on chad davil's
property
in fremont county idaho they were found
after law enforcement discovered a text
from chad davil to his now deceased wife
tammy
matching that text with geola location
data from the phone of lori davil's now
deceased
brother alex cox gave law enforcement
the location of
the children's bodies the day bells are
charged with conspiracy because the
evidence which the state
will present shows that there was a plan
between the defendants in regards to the
fate
of lori daybel's children the evidence
in this case the state police will
demonstrate that the concealment of
tyler and jj's bodies
are the result of the same plan and the
same series of acts or transactions
which constitute the offense
for which both defendants are charged
and that is the standard set forth in
rule
8b chad dabel's defense argues that
while the allegations against both
defendants are similar having their
trials at the same time would cause
prejudice
but mr wood's argument judge to suggest
a convenience to the court
and expense to the county and the
difficulty
of witnesses is secondary and primarily
judge the importance is
is mr dabell going to get a fair
opportunity to present his side of the
story
and is it going to be able to be
presented without any kind of
prejudice or bias or are they going to
infer anything from any other witness
or any other defendant or anybody else
that does not afford him an opportunity
to fairly present his case
the fact remains is what i would ask the
court to do is reserve
a ruling on jointer allow the argument
to be made
in terms of severance once mr wood and i
have resolved our discovery issues
and and decide at that point whether or
not we're going to proceed
in a common trial the judge said he did
agree with the prosecutor's arguments
and issued his ruling right on the spot
i think quite concerning giving our
circumstances right now under
our coveted restrictions and the
difficulties we have even getting a jury
trial
at this point the
prospect of having two separate trials
where two separate juries would have to
be empaneled to try each case
is concerning as well and so upon
consideration of all that council i am
going to grant the motion to join at
this time
um as the parties indicated that doesn't
forego the possibility of a future
motion for severance if
uh prejudice is demonstrated by the
defense in support of that motion
and remember lori valodebel did not
object to the state's motion to have the
cases tried together
but she did file several of her own
arguments nonetheless law on crime's
terry austin is here to explain
what lori vela wants from the judge
terry
erin lloyd valodevo was not present at
this hearing but she has filed court
papers demanding authorities release
more information in the case against her
defense attorney mark means is
requesting recordings
emails text messages social media posts
and reports regarding
chad day bell and other possible
witnesses those include balo's
former friends and even her own children
prosecutors say
they've given the defense some of the
items but not all of the material is
available yet
so terry among velo's defense requests
are autopsy and toxicology reports for
the kids and
now other deceased people as well social
media posts recordings
is this a fishing expedition or is this
a legitimate request
you know what aaron i don't think it's a
phishing expedition i think it's a
legitimate request and i think that
these requests
indicate that laurie's attorneys maybe
not laurie
but the attorneys are gearing up to
point the finger
either at chad day bell or even laurie's
deceased brother alex because i think
they are trying to find
information that will take the charges
away from her and towards somebody
anybody else
interesting tactic interesting theory
there terry remember she's the mother
brian let's look at the law here every
state seems to play the discovery game a
little bit differently
idaho criminal rule 16 says the
prosecutor
has to turn over automatically
everything which makes the defendant
appear not guilty that's pretty standard
or which would reduce the punishment
that's also pretty standard but then
they've also got
a laundry list of other rules require
the prosecutor to hand over
other things if the defense requests it
in writing so it seems like here
the defense is just exercising its
ability to
ask and receive absolutely that's the
defense attorney's
job to get all the information possible
and to try to
show that their client or at least
defend their client in the best as
possible because you gotta remember
the defense attorney does not have the
resources that the government has
to investigate the arm of the law
prosecutors
judges uh not judges sorry officers and
other things at their disposal
but we're trying to seek justice here
not punishment and that involves getting
all the information
and real quick i think we called it here
i think we all said that these cases
would probably be joined together and
terry that's exactly what the judge did
yes and i think it makes sense it saves
time it saves resources
and frankly they're going to probably
point the finger at each other at the
end of the day
exactly that's a common tactic we'll
have to watch the trial as it unfolds
they're moving very quickly in that
direction
jury selection is beginning in the trial
of a colorado man accused of murdering
his son
59 year old mark redwine is accused of
killing 13 year old dylan in 2012.
the father wasn't indicted until five
years later when new people started
looking into the case
the father faces second degree murder
and child abuse charges
prosecutors think the victim found
so-called compromising photos of his
father
which may have resulted in his death
let's check in now with chief
investigative correspondent brian ross
and what he's working on this week
thanks erin coming up this week on brian
ross investigates
does the punishment fit the crime the
department of justice announces a
settlement with the makers of oxycontin
the purdue farmer company
they agree to pay 8.3 billion dollars
and the company will plead guilty to
three felony counts
but no criminal charges against any
executives of the company
or the owners of the company the sackler
family
does the punishment fit the crime we'll
talk with nan golden the artist who led
protest
against purdue pharma people wrote to
congratulate me
but this isn't a win it's a spin
there's no justice in this case that's
this week
i'm brian ross investigates erin on the
law and crime trial network
we'll see you there brian and still
ahead here on law and crime daily we'll
discuss a request by the mother of
police shooting victim brianna taylor to
have a new prosecutor look at her case
plus sentencing for a convicted chicago
cop killer we'll break down the charges
and the sentence
when law on crime daily returns in just
a moment
philadelphia is experiencing several
nights of civil unrest following the
police shooting of a black man armed
with a knife
a witness recorded this video and posted
it on instagram it shows officers
following walter wallace jr who was
carrying the knife
the video has been viewed close to 2
million times
wallace's family told the philadelphia
tv station that they called for an
ambulance to help him
with a mental health problem they say
they did not request the police the city
has asked residents and parts of the
city to stay
inside during the unrest the national
guard is being mobilized to bring the
protests under control
to kentucky now where the mother of
police shooting victim briana taylor is
demanding a new prosecutor look into the
death
of her daughter
tamika palmer says in a 109 page request
that a competent and capable prosecutor
willing to handle the case involving the
officers who shot and killed her
daughter
should be appointed by a kentucky office
known as the prosecutor's advisory
council
palmer calls her request nerve-wracking
but says someone other than state
attorney general daniel cameron
must review the case here's how she
described her own interactions with the
a.g
following the proceedings attorney
general daniel cameron had meade drive
nearly an
hour to his office in frankfort where he
proceeded to tell me that
his prosecution team was only able to
obtain an indictment against lmpd
officer brett hakinson
the attorney general advised me that the
grand jury declined to indict other
officers
and that his team had done the best they
could a.g cameron and one of his
prosecutors
then advised me that i should consider
finding peace through the lord
and watched as i sobbed uncontrollably
palmer described having to pull off the
highway on her way home
because she was sick over what was said
meanwhile cameron was telling the press
that the grand jury determined
the shooting was justified he announced
to a worldwide audience that his
prosecutors
walked the grand jury through every
homicide offense that the grand jury
applied the facts to the law
and that the grand jury upon reviewing
the evidence determined that the
officers were justified in killing
brianna
these statements were flat out lies
palmer's document says
so brian the anguish that that mother
felt is something that
i felt reading the documents but you've
looked into the law underlying this and
we were talking earlier you
aren't sure she has a strong argument
legally speaking
yeah so the law that she's citing to
unfortunately and i think it goes
throughout the entirety of this case
that it doesn't seem like the law has
the equipment to properly give justice
to brianna taylor
the law that she's citing to would
typically be used to take a case out of
a county district attorney's hand
and give it to that of the attorney
general but it doesn't really give
guidance
as to what happens when the attorney
general messes up in such a way
and to give it to someone else and so
it's almost like the law has been
failing brianna taylor
over and over and over again and this is
where reform movements come from
terry let's talk about the attorney
general's statements because
the mother is really throwing the book
back at the attorney general do you
think he
thought that this uproar would swell up
with
grand jurors speaking publicly speaking
on television
filing lawsuits to be able to speak and
now we have an entirely different
narrative of what went on in that secret
proceeding
well that's exactly right and listen
this is why i agree with brian actually
i think it's going to be hard
to get another attorney general or
prosecutor to
handle this case but i think cameron
should recruit himself and he should
recuse himself because
on the one hand he told the grand jury
that this is all there is he didn't
present
all of the homicide offenses and on the
other hand he's announcing in public
that he did just that so he lied
and i think it's a conflict and i think
he should save all of us and
step down harsh opinions from terry
and great legal insight from both of you
terry and brian and still to come here
on law and crime daily we'll
take you back to the trial of a pro
baseball player accused of using a bat
as a murder weapon
but first a convicted cop killer faces
his victim's family
and learns his fate in a chicago
sentencing hearing we're back with that
in just a moment
[Music]
a sentencing hearing for a man convicted
of killing a chicago police commander
law on crime's brian buckmeyer has that
report brian more than two years after
commander paul bower was shot to death
his family now says they're relieved but
that justice will never be served so
long as the defendant is still alive
shamari legetti entered court for a
final time as a judge preparing to hand
down his sentence
investigators say legetti was dressed in
body armor and was holding a gun with an
extended magazine
as he gunned down commander bauer in a
stairwell in february of 2018.
police officers worked to capture a
suspect for killing one of their own
a man who viciously murdered a chicago
police officer
was convicted on all accounts here was a
man who had devoted his entire life
to his family and the city of chicago
and he was taken from us far too soon
the late commander's widow and daughter
spoke about bauer's life
how he loved to read and cared deeply
for his family
we'll never stop mourning the loss but
we're delighted that there was justice
today
a jury convicted legetti of six charges
including first degree murder of a law
enforcement officer
a defense motion for a new trial was
denied it is the sentence of this court
that the defendant
shomari legetti shall serve life in
prison
without the possibility of parole
it's a tough sentence brian what's the
status of the death penalty in illinois
we heard that the family said that they
wouldn't feel that they were
truly receiving justice while the
defendant was still alive
so if you went back before 2011 2010 if
you had murdered someone in the first
degree
that's a life sentence but if you had
done it to a peace officer or to another
governmental official then the death
penalty was on the table however even
back in 2002 the former governor back
then was
commuting sentences for the death
penalty but as of 2011
that was disbanded so even if it's on
the books technically
there's no death penalty in illinois
yeah terry most states do
increase penalties for the killings of
police officers firefighters and other
government services and
there is still an inkling of that in
illinois law
that's right and you know most states do
it and there's a reason for that
including here in new york state the
rationale is that
when you kill a police officer or
another government official who's there
to serve you to protect you you should
have a higher sentence you should have
the maximum sentence that you can
possibly get because they're there to
protect you
and it's particularly heinous when those
individuals are
killed in the course of their duty to
protect you
such a sad case all the way around brian
i know that you looked into this
this a lot earlier was the punishment
the proper one here no chance at parole
i think it is um i i'm again
i'm always the defense attorney i want
people to have the ability to redeem
themselves but when i look at the facts
when i look at the two-page letter that
he sent to the family
his lack of remorse uh i think he has a
constitutional right to be defended and
i would do
that but as a human being i think this
is the right punishment
and i think the court found the right
the right decision
i think we find the right decisions when
we have due process and good defense
work results in due process when we have
due process we can feel comfortable
with the outcomes of cases it sounds
like here we three agree that that
in our opinions is what happened when we
come back
is it a crime punishable by death or a
mental health disorder which led to a
tragedy
that's the choice a california jury must
make in the trial of a baseball player
accused of triple murder
that case is coming up next
[Music]
a former professional baseball player is
on trial after authorities say he used a
baseball bat to beat
three people to death brandon willie
martin faces three counts of
first-degree murder for the deaths of
his father his uncle
and a security system installer who just
happened to be there
prosecutors accused martin of committing
the murders out of anger after losing
his baseball contract
the defense says martin suffers from
mental illness police say martin fled
the murders
after committing the crimes leading them
on a high-speed chase through
residential neighborhoods
i yelled at him to put his hands outside
the window
and in case he couldn't hear me i also
used my pa system that's inside our
vehicle to
put his hands out the window we're not
going to
walk up to a vehicle on a high risk stop
that's not how we're trained
the way we're trained is we're going to
call the person back to us
okay and did you do that no why is that
we didn't have the opportunity to and
why is that
as we were still set up the i saw the
driver's hands
tucked back into the truck and
the truck then set off i remember it
leaving at a high rate of speed
that was concerning for me given we're
in a residential community
from there martin fled again the
officer's backup unit was able to follow
him through the neighborhood until he
eventually collided
with the police cruiser as a
determination of that
pursuit or where it ended i saw the
subject
he get out of the vehicle and start
running norfolk on
and are and you're familiar with that
area yeah
okay uh when you saw the suspect uh
leave uh and start going on uh towards
buena vista what did you do
i immediately went around this was a
collision between
a unit and the raptor i went around
both units and the raptor and followed
the subject
while he was running i was on my unit
for my car okay
and uh were you able to stop him
no where did the subject go he went over
a
it was like an old wooden brown fence
in one of us more units arrived to
surround the house a police helicopter
provided air support
and k-9 units joined on the ground
he was on the ground laying down with
his back towards us
motionless okay and did you call out to
the suspect
at that point our k-9 officer did
immediately the dog will kind of
poke the person around a little bit
first i did it
and then it actually latched onto him
and i can't remember where
the dog's biting and the handler still
giving him orders to comply
so he was punching the dog if the dog's
biting me here and
he was kind of just hitting the dog in
the top of the head
i saw when uh it's almost like an old
wrestling move
where the dog kind of was picked up and
then dropped on his top of his head
like he picked him up and dropped him on
it that's when we all jumped in
uh like towards the top of his head so
like where he was being latched
where the dog was latched at in between
the lower region
he was just kind of slammed down
corporal bennett removed the dog from
the bite
but we took the subject to the ground
at which point he landed on his stomach
this is vicious okay so terry it seems
to me legally that the defendant's
flight
might get in the way of his insanity
defense under california law and
insanity defense
asks these questions one did he
understand
that he was doing something that was
criminal or two
did he understand it was morally wrong
so if he fled
arguably he knew it was wrong or that it
was criminal
right aaron i agree 100
and you know here's the point generally
when a defendant
attempts to flee the scene it means that
there is some consciousness of guilt
but i'm sure and i think brian is going
to agree here
it could also indicate that the
defendant had some other explanation for
why he
fled i mean perhaps he was delusional he
thought everyone was trying to get him
the police were
you know in some sort of conspiracy to
hurt him and and that's why he fled but
i agree with you it does seem to me that
he knew
he was wrong okay brian take it away
here if you want to disagree with us
both
go for it right now so i disagree with
you both okay first and foremost
when the insanity defense is applied
it's applied to the time in which the
incident occurred not the flight
thereafter
second of all when we're talking about
the insanity defense it's whether or not
they understand that it's criminal or
moral fight or flight is instinctual
there is an actual part of the brain
that is triggered
when an individual is fleeing from
something i've got a 70 pound doberman
that is trained in a similar way to
those
officers are trained and i'm talking
about the canine unit if you want to try
being chased by one of by my dog aaron
trust me it's fight or flight and that's
not something that you're actually
consciously deciding it's something your
body is reacting to look i've seen
pictures of your dog if your dog comes
after me
i'm running i'm not fighting back that's
just not going to happen well look
a couple of different views on this the
jury's going to have to decide brian and
terry great discussions here as always
thank you for watching here on long
crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america and there's a lot to
talk about
[Music]
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions
we break down the case of a serial
killer another day of drama between both
sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming
the law on crime network is everywhere
and we invite
you inside the jury box this is law and
[Music]
crime
[Music]
[Music]
you